[موسيقى]
شارع الحمراء بيقدر اكثر شيء ترجم الوضع
العام مثل ما هو انحدار الحمراء اكتر شارع
كان جامع المجتمعات اللبنانيه قاطبه بما
فيها مختلف طوائفها واختلف ثقافاتها
عاداتها تقاليدها جمع بين الريفي والمدنيه
تناقضات اللي كانت تجتمع بالحمره كانت
بتتشكل المزيج اللبناني الذي مكونات البلد
اذا بدنا نحكي عن السينمائيات والمصالح
اللي هي اساسا كان شارع الحمراء هو مثل
المنطقه الثقافات همم خلال اخر الستينيات
اول السبعينات كان همم هو اللي يسمع كلمه
رواد
حتى المقاهي المرتبطه في كانت مرتبطه
حصريا برواد السينمائيات
والمسيح للاسف يعني مع غياب المسيح اغلاق
المسيح واغلاق هايدي المجتمعات فقط في
تغير شارع الحمل لصالح التجاره وح التجاره
انت قلت من الالبسه مثلا للاكسسريس ظلال
غير وغيره حسب النمط الاقتصادي او المسار
الاقتصادي هيك انا من مواليد
1975 انا شهادت يعني عشر او تسع نماذج
للشارع الحمراء منه شارع الحمراء فوضوي
بالحرب يكون في المسارح والسينما بس بيكون
على اطرافه لاعبين الورق على الطريق بيرجع
تحول الشارع المستقبل للماكولات والمطاعم
رجع كمان تحول همم
ملابس
كمان ومسرح المدينه طبيعه الحال والمتر
حاليا
كنا اول مره بنشوف حشد لبناني خارج السياق
الحرب وال والزعماكي انا بتذكر شارع
الحمراء
الاوليه يعني كونه من مواليد ب 75 بتذكر
الويندوز لانهم اشهر مقهى بتذكر الموتكا
بتذكر كافيه دو فريق الصوره عندي بعد
مغبشه شويه انما بعدني بنسكر هيدا الحمراء
اللي انا وعيت عليه شفته بالحرب يعني بعز
الحرب ورجع نهر وشفته كبيره ورجعت ما هو
كمان همم يعني هاي بيروت والحمره بالنهايه
حتى لو نختلف او اخذت هيك الطريقه المستقل
او الشكل المستقل ببيروت الا لما بيبقى هو
ايه همم
الاشاره الحمراء ولا يتحول شارع الحمراء
لانوس
[موسيقى]